good what's driving you crazy of course
the shutdown of the ramps from the south
15 to Trop is just the beginning of
Tropicana
after Saturday night's Golden Knights
game at T-Mobile
Tropicana gets real with an eight-day
complete closure of both directions of
Tropicana from Dean Martin to New York
New York so what do you do with trop
closed well the easy answer would be
Flamingo Russell for East West travel
and that sounds good until you stop to
realize that thousands of other drivers
are going to be thinking the exact same
thing so here are three suggestions for
you for your East West travel while
Trump is closed Desert Inn
Harman
or Hacienda
again this all starts after the Golden
Knights game on Saturday night the
complete closure of Tropicana we want
that to sink in because it does get even
worse the bigger closure will be I-15
itself the freeway shutting down between
Flamingo and Russell buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the drive any crazy
conversation where traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com